every business needs to have a face for
their company if you don't have a face
for your business you're going to lose
out because people buy from people
people trust people people look up to
people people care about people people
don't care about a logo I work with a
lot of big brands who are trying to sell
to the entrepreneur community and one of
the biggest things that hold most of
them back is there's no face for the
business there's nobody we can look to
and say that person really understands
me that person gets me I now have
loyalty towards this business and if you
don't have that then what's going to
happen is as soon as your competitor
drop surprised by five or ten percent
you're going to lose a whole chunk of
business because there is no loyalty
there's no caring there's no affinity
towards a logo where it could be if you
had a face for your brain the face for
the company could be the CEO at the
highest level of your company but it
could also be a middle manager who just
really pashley but cares about the
audience I'm going to share a couple of
examples for you the first one is
Richard Branson Richard Branson is very
active on his blog he's active on
Twitter he puts YouTube videos up and
here is somebody who genuinely cares
about people and when he's tweeting out
he has the usual corporate stop
promoting the Virgin something is
working on but he'll also stand up for
the fight on drugs and you'll stand up
to protecting languages and they'll
stand up for promoting innovation here's
someone who cares who is authentic who
spreads his message through these
mediums and as a result we care about
him and Richard Branson is not the
greatest speaker he's not the most
eloquent speaker he stutters a lot and
yet we love him because he's genuine we
feel like he cares about us and so we
are going to care about him and there's
immense loyalty towards the Virgin brand
another example of Stephen Kelly he's
the CEO of sage into accounting software
and the stuff that Stephen puts out is
way more corporate and more what you
would expect from a CEO of a big
business talking about things he's doing
talking about events that are going on
showing pictures of him with his team
pictures of him with customers that's
the stuff that you'd normally expect
from a CEO but he put out this one tweet
that blew my mind you put on a tweet
that said here's to the risk takers the
hard workers the go-getters small and
medium businesses sage is with you
hashtag small biz I read that unlike
what this is amazing like here's
somebody who cares about me here's
someone who understands entrepreneurs
and says staying with me like yeah now I
have emotional connection towards
Stephen and I also which would post more
of these things between was attract a
much more laurel audience and Bill
tremendous loyalty towards his company
sage but not all CEOs are open to that
not all CEOs want to beat the face not
all CEOs want to tell their story which
I believe is a huge mistake but if
you're working at a big company there
are still solutions be it yourself right
I remember there's one new small
business manager at Microsoft and they
had this event to welcome him and he got
on stage he was talking about this store
and how he grew up in the family of
entrepreneurs and his parents were
florist and he grew up in the flower
shop business and talked about the
trials and tribulations that they went
through and how he had to see you know
both the ups and the downs of
entrepreneurship through his parents and
just listen to him talk make me feel
like here is a guy who gets it here is a
God who cares about entrepreneurs and
understands them and not just some
corporate stiff trying to sell me stuff
right there's that negative bias towards
big companies because entrepreneur you
like you don't care about us you don't
really know what we're going through
you're just trying to sell us product
and the way to break through that is to
have an authentic face to represent your
brand because people will never be loyal
to a brand people will never be loyal to
logo people won't care about a logo to
care about a person and they won't care
about you until you show that you care
about them first so have a face for your
brand
so my question for you guys today is
which brand you look up to that has a
face for their company and you have now
created this kind of loyalty an
attachment you feel that they really
care about you so you care about them
I'm really curious to find out leaving
the comments below I'll I'm gonna join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon